[Music]
Matt Winston great to meet you great to
meet you too so you want to learn the
banjo I do my wife gave me a banjo 12
years ago and it's been sitting as a
decoration on all of my sets the
audience judges me for not being able to
play the banjo I've promised that I'll
play it and I never have
and uh now I feel like now it's time
it's time to do this now the time what's
what's happened now that made you think
basically my producers forced me to so
that's why we're sitting here right now
day 100 of begging Matt to play the
banjo for us
well Scott I know I did promise I do I
remember my promises and I know I
promised and you've been putting this in
the comments for 100 days and I promised
a while ago that if you keep this going
for 100 days I will play the banjo and I
am a man
of my word my big question is
because I've always admired people who
can play instruments and it's almost
like you know it's a second language
really you can speak in the language of
music right
uh can I learn this and master it in
about
30 minutes
well the key
is a finger Fitness finger Fitness yes
okay
um I'm not sure if you have any
experience in finger Fitness
I don't I guess not no well um I think
that perhaps if you haven't an
experience we might sort of need some
sort of finger boot camp
so uh okay
um I guess I know what I'm agreeing to
think of the most intimidating army boot
camp you can but just fingers
everything you're saying is making this
weirder and weirder as we go along well
look you've given me a day well 30
minutes yeah 30 minutes to get you to
Performance level okay
you know it's it's going to be tough
very good
push yourself
and another
stuff
feel the burn
[Music]
weirdest thing I've ever filmed
very good
I want this in the same circuit every
day this doesn't feel
are you doing normal necessary
it's very necessary I did this for years
before I even did you did this exact
thing for years
but you're not you've got to do the
whole movement otherwise you don't work
the muscles properly
very it feels like I'm just molesting
mature
and you're watching that's exactly right
the other part is you've got to choose
your finger picks okay I didn't know
sort of the size of your thumbs so I
bought a variety here we can go into the
fitting room maybe get a bit of privacy
you need privacy with me for this yeah
well I think perhaps not with the whole
crew here
I'd rather have them here
okay now that
I'm feeling slightly uncomfortable
so there's actually just two options
okay medium or large
so large actually start with your thumbs
all right
hand actually sorry oh okay
feel good
uh
I don't know how it's supposed to feel
but is that it should feel weird okay
yeah well it does okay okay all right so
you want to get them on tight
okay there you go well done all right
I'm ready to play the bands you're ready
to play you're ready to pick
okay you know I know I've uh broken some
promises in the past allegedly but I'm
now starting the process of amending
those wrongs I'm not the only one who
has broken some promises though you ever
noticed how corporations will promise
you one thing but give you another take
search engines for example Google claims
that incognito mode allows for private
browsing but it doesn't actually hide
your activity in fact it doesn't matter
what mode you use or how many times you
clear your browsing history your
internet service provider your employer
school and other unwelcome eyes can
still see every single website you've
ever visited that's why I never go
online without using expressvpn it
doesn't matter who your internet
provider is in the US they can legally
sell your information to ad companies a
true violation of trust if I've ever
heard of one expressvpn is an app that
reroutes all of your online activity
through their secure servers so that
your ISP workplace or network admin
can't monitor it expressvpn also
encrypts 100 of your data to protect you
from hackers expressvpn is incredibly
easy to use and it's available on all
your devices just tap one button and
you're protected here's a promise you
can count on when you visit my exclusive
Link at expressvpn.com walshyt you'll
get an extra three months free that's
exp rssvpn.com walshyt for three months
free expressvpn.com Walsh YT
actually the banjo is much easier than
you think okay so you don't even need
your left hand
just get your thumb okay and go
[Music]
chord of G
I record in how many chords are there
three okay but the truth as well the
truth is quite key three chords and the
truth
and I got you know
no your left hand yeah one finger
okay
down like that across the fifth fret so
where the little one two three four five
[Music]
got two chords all right pretty good
yeah it's a natural that was uh what did
we just do G and C okay that was C that
I just did yeah okay keep it keep it on
the c one two three four five
and then up two more
one two yeah
as good as yours
there's your D
okay so there you got your three chords
now how do I put it all together to make
a song
foreign
okay
[Music]
wait do it again
I think you can do it right do it one
more time
[Music]
I can do that that I got done this I've
mastered I've mastered this part of it
that's hot and then uh
[Music]
okay
well this is Passion okay good all right
uh I
uh so do we think we could try melody or
is it too soon I think I'm ready so if
you just can you just play that that
string
perfect and then using your left hand
on the first fret
and then
that's the first two notes of Dueling
Banjos this is really quite something
[Music]
[Applause]
you got it did I do something you got it
oh I did yeah
I think I'm ready I think I am ready I
think I understand the banjo now
I think merely but you know sure let's
just let's Dive In
yeah okay
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]